welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Ruth Barnes the Thomas Jaffe curator
of indo-pacific art at the yale
university art gallery dr. Barnes is an
art historian in the field of South and
Southeast Asian textiles with a
particular interest in the social
history of material culture and the
anthropological interpretation and has
studied textiles from South and
Southeast Asia as well as from the
Islamic world from this perspective
today we talked with dr. Barnes about
the new indo-pacific gallery that just
opened this past December welcome dr.
Barnes thank you welcome it's so nice to
have you her and I have to say
congratulations to because the gallery
that just opened open to such
spectacular rave reviews I've actually
been there myself and I think it is
fantastic so kudos to thank you very
much let's start with you giving us an
overview of the gallery right the
collection is really very new it's
totally new to the gallery and it is
probably new material for most of our
visitors and for that reason I really
tried very much given overview and a and
a general introduction to the to the
material from maritime Southeast Asia
which is the main focus of our
collections eventually we hope that we
will also include material from the
oceanic world but that is not on display
at the moment and so I'm is it just I'm
sorry just interrupt for one second so
what are the countries then that are
represented on the gallery it's
Indonesia it's Malaysia the Philippines
and because the the people of that
region are belong to a cultural and
linguistic group called austronesian
that expect
extends from Taiwan all the way to
Madagascar but has its focus in maritime
Southeast Asia we also include some a
small collection from the Taiwanese
aboriginal population so but the main
focus is Indonesia the Philippines okay
so continue about the overview of the
gallery yes look so he says we present
the cultures of the region and that is
that is a general introduction but I
also wanted to introduce specific themes
that are very relevant to people from
the area such as head hunting and
warfare head hunting is something that
seems very alien to western US and well
as yet haunting it it was part of
warfare formerly in in the region but it
also had a very important ritual purpose
it was basically a growing of age
occasion young men had to go out and be
near to prove themselves as young adults
to go out on headhunting raids and also
heads were often taken from from enemy
groups to be part of building village
temples or important ceremonial houses
that is the past we're talking about the
heads of people that's right okay so
this is in the past I also introduced
the the importance and the role of
ancestors in the spirit world and there
is a small display on lifecycle
ceremonies there's also a display that
looks at the earliest surviving forms of
art which are mostly metal work
from going back to or in some cases
3,000 years and these are objects that
show patterns that are still relevant
now if you go to the gallery you may
look out for for example for a little
bronze seated man who's playing a
musical instrument his back is very
elaborately decorated with tattoos now
this figure is from the from the very
early first century BC and right next to
it I display some some stamps that were
used in Borneo to be to be covered with
with black paint and then then stamped
onto the human body as a guide for
making tattoos and they show virtually
the same intricate patterns I think that
is a very interesting connection let's
talk about your role as a curator mm-hmm
you know what kinds of things do you do
perhaps maybe give us a life in the day
of dr. Ruth Barnes well of course I am
first of all responsible for making the
the collection accessible so I am I'm
the person that was responsible for
designing and choosing the objects and
designing the overall display but I did
that very much in collaboration with
with our design team I involved of
course the conservators the our
publication department works closely
with me when it comes to writing labels
and interpreting the material so that it
we make sure that it is actually
accessible specialists are often not the
the best people for
for communicating what they know in
great detail so the wonderful part of
working in the museum for me it's always
that it involves working with so many
different people who have vastly
different talents some of it very hands
on some of it very much intellectual and
academic planning and research focused
and it really makes you feel quite
humble about the different talents that
we all bring to our jobs to work in the
museum and bring it all together into
into something that becomes a creative
and inspiring display right so tell us
what was your goal your ultimate goal in
curating the eggs the installation
because this material is probably quite
new to many of our visitors I really
wanted to in to introduce this
collection or these collections in a way
that is accessible but also makes people
marvel at the ingenuity and the
creativity that speaks through these
objects and what's what is the time span
that the gallery shows pieces from the
earliest material that we display goes
back right to the prehistory of
Southeast Asia these are metal works
bronze objects that go back to the that
have an age of about between three and
four thousand years but the the main the
chronology of the most of our collection
involves the go go's from
on the seventh eighth century AD right
to the present that is studied into the
20th century and in some places early
21st century the there are three main
parts to the collection there is the
large group of of three-dimensional
objects mostly wood sculpture that is in
date I would say most of that is 18 to
the early 20th century then there is a
fabulous collection of textiles which
goes back to an earlier period and our
earliest textiles have i've actually
been able to do some radiocarbon dating
on some of them our earliest textiles go
back to this 15 16th century and then we
have a large collection of about 500
gold objects from central and east java
and that collection dates to the eighth
to the root of the 13th century and so
it has a large chronological range and I
think it is important to have to make
visitors aware of of that time dish and
so I'm very pleased that we able to do
that ok so let me ask you this is now
the exhibit at the Yale gallery the
largest or one of the largest in this
country it certainly is and it also is
of superb quality I think it has very
few rivals in my opinion it really is a
probably the most outstanding collection
of its of its type there are important
collections in elsewhere in the country
but because this is the univer
thirsty museum we also offer the
opportunity of involving students
involving the general public in in
teaching sessions in and we really
invite the the public to make use of our
collections in a way that that enhances
learning and appreciation okay now
moving forward you have pieces that are
in storage now that you will rotate out
at some point yes that affects in
particular the the textiles of course
there's a constant rotation that will
take place and every certainly every six
months we will have new things out
exhales there's a reason i go back
shortly but also eventually i would like
to have a part of the of the gallery
dedicated to more focused in-depth
displays either for a particular from a
particular geographic region or covering
a particular aspect of life that one
finds represented through throughout the
region for one could for example look at
at the consumption of beetle which is a
mixture of it's it's a palm nut arecanut
and the fruit or leap of the siri pepper
which is mixed with lime and is a mild
narcotic that is used throughout the
region it probably originated in
Southeast Asia in spread to South Asia
it's very popular mayor to have a true
in in India as well but it's it's very
common in Southeast Asia and because it
is part of all
social exchange that is fast like I'd
never heard of that has a beautiful
interesting paraphernalia that are
connected with us it's like having wine
cups there are wonderful baskets that
were made specifically to hold the
different parts that go into making a
beetle quid there are line boxes lime as
in chalk there are betelnut cutters and
we have wonderful examples for all of
this which we could have a small display
that we don't you introduce is that that
is it very interesting we could also
have I would very much like we have very
strong collection from Borneo okay and I
think Borneo would appeal as an as
focused exhibition to the general public
because people are very aware of
environmental issues from that vary from
that large island the the exploration of
and and destruction of rainforests and
flora and fauna that that have been
affected by that we could present
wonderful works of art from the region
but we could have in collaboration with
that maybe have a conference or have
research projects that bring in Yale's
school of Forestry or people who are
scientists who work in environmental
studies in general let me ask you this
of the collection there today talk about
a few of your favorite pieces and why
they're your favorites that's really a
hard time I you know something that we
can go and look for when we're sure i
would say among the among be and
sculptures i'm very fond input
killer of one ancestor head from the
island of leyte it it is and it's it
it's the head with a with the upper
torso is shown and very beautifully
simply well very very simply carved with
very plain facial features very refined
and then it the the head has an
elaborate headdress that is extremely
ornate and beautifully carved earrings
as well with spiral patterns and I think
that's a very exquisite piece in general
I think the Borneo wood carving is as
good as it as carving can get it's
really extraordinary of course i love
the textiles yes and i love all of them
and so there will always be something
new to look for in that from that
collection among the gold pieces I very
much admire the they wonderfully worked
exquisite ear ornaments we have to Chris
that is dagger Java new type of javanese
dagger Chris handles that are very very
beautifully worked but I think what is
probably most touching for me in that
particular collection a small gold leaf
temple offerings and they move me in
particular because they represent the
hopes and the prayers of people who
lived more than a thousand years ago how
in that I find
a day it just affects me yes well this
has been so much fun from a I thank you
for being here and sharing your work at
the Museum thank you very much mr.
pleasure thank you for more information
about dr. Barnes and her work at the
Museum please visit our website at yale
edu / macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you